[Music]
hello
hey
i'm reluctant again to put my headphones
on because i think i have slightly
dabbing their hair again not quite as
debonair hair it's not as good as it was
last week i'll put it i'll put it on
here we go how's it going uh pretty good
yeah see that looks like a pig's ass now
no it still looks good really yeah
you've got that little quiff at the
front yeah that will always be there no
matter how much you want to flatten down
the rest i'm not sure if there's anyone
out there in terms of you know the new
technologies in
hair
transplants that wants to a sponsor the
show and b
give me
not you had to wonder give me a free
hair transplant i could maybe talk you
through the whole process during this
podcast you want to make sure you get a
good one though
yeah we have
had run-ins with people over the years
that have had poor hair transplant
somebody but then that made me think
that all of them are poor no but
obviously there's people who's had them
that are i've seen those people and
didn't know they had them
and that would be the good ones well
we'll keep those people nameless because
we don't want to offend those people but
i had mentioned to you a couple of
people off camera one time i said well
he's definitely had it and he's had it
and i know that he's had it and you were
amazed by that weren't you yeah was
amazed sometimes um
billy i brought you a cake i saw that i
can't even concentrate because i'm
thinking about this cake you can dive
right in right now because there are two
hidden ingredients in this cake is it
chocolate and corn flakes which no no i
want you to isolate i was i was simply
using up ingredients in my house and
what what i mean by using up ingredients
was i had a bag of eggs which i'll keep
a mystery because you're gonna find out
what that is later i did have to go out
and buy cornflakes and unsalted butter
and chocolate but i'll tell you what
these are a smash hit i tell you what i
saw you taking these out the fridge
there but i didn't know that you'd
actually made them i'll move them what
kind of chocolate is that
well
oh what's that it's a brand name so i
can't say the name of chocolate but well
you can if the if the um you know the
thing with the show what did you call it
sponsor if they sponsor a show we should
get a dictionary to sponsor you
two hidden ingredients have you got one
of them yet one of them's really obvious
is there's something in there that is
soft it's visual there you go you got
one there ah yeah that's a marshmallow
with that correct there's a mini
marshmallow in there yup and then
something else which you know me well
enough to probably be able to
guess what that hidden ingredient is
well i don't think it's a raisin not a
raisin
you know what i don't like raisins and
curry
i'm not a fan of raisins in curry either
i don't like that they swell you know
take on some of the liquid and yeah and
they're all like big and
bulbous i guess is a word for that but i
tell you what the simple
luxury of a chocolate corn flake cake
like with a cup of tea i've been doing
this over the last few days absolutely
spectacular i'll tell you what dom
there's no way i'm not going to finish
this now finish it i'm going to finish
mine too but do you think that's okay in
the show to just be eating a conflict
cake
i'll tell you what
that's delicious that dumb
can you not tell the other no not yet
but hold on is it visual the other one
not visual so you've got up to now
cornflakes unsalted butter
chocolate mini marshmallows there's one
more thing in this mixture it's subtle
but it's there knowing you will be
something weird like a cayenne pepper
you've got it cayenne pepper it was a
tiny little hint well why is it like
three grains a granule i remember
thinking because i'd made a terrible uh
mistake on new year's eve with you and
your family where i made what was
supposed to be an apple and berry
crumble and i thought i'll spice up this
crust this crumble i'll put a tiny
little bit of spice and it'll just give
them just something to think about but
instead it became a spicy crumble didn't
it and to be honest i've always said it
was okay but i think we're far enough
away from christmas now to say that that
spoiled that crap it was shine it was
absolutely i was absolutely shy no it
was still tasty your son liked it he
loved it but
i i learned from my mistake and i
thought less is more
yeah apart from situations where more is
more like when you're acting yeah always
always give more always that's what
every actor that's what every director
says to me more more dumb more
performance
um
so i thought right i'll do less is more
and i simply took
the the glass vessel love that word
not glass vessel uh that the cayenne
pepper was in
and just it went like this if you if
you're only listening to the podcast
you're going to miss it here but you'll
you'll see it i went i'll just grab it i
went
it gave it one shake tiny but you know
how small the granules of cayenne pepper
are it's quite a lot
gave it a stir taste it and i thought
yeah you might not know but then every
so often you go oh a little bit of spice
i think i feel it on my lips more than
taste it on my tongue mm-hmm that's the
thing about cayenne pepper cayenne
pepper is fantastically good for you you
should put it in anything that you can
between cayenne pepper and turmeric it's
anti-inflammatory
kills cancer cells makes you run faster
does it make you run faster if it makes
you run faster
is there a go-to cake that if you're
right up against it you would make
um that i knew that i could make yeah
in my head i would say shortbread right
but i did try to make shortbread the
other day thinking i was a master of it
and it was really awful that's a shame
i was making it for the neighbor as well
oh because they're from argentina and
they gave us an argentinian
cake right
and they're argentinian cake it was
absolutely delicious and i thought to
myself i'll make them some shortbread
you know from scotland
and it was trash
absolute trash i think you're a good
cook yeah i thought over the years that
you now spent together you're quite
adept in the kitchen not intimidated by
a kitchen by any means you can get uh
get stuff going
but there has been a couple of notable
failures the one i'm thinking of is the
sushi in new zealand remember that you
were really excited about that i did it
was it yeah i bought the thing
the kind of rolling devices was like
really tightly packed pieces of wood you
put the rice in there and the fish and
then you tightly pack it and stuff but
it's not about that is it it's about the
rice it's the race that's getting the
rice right gotta get the rice and to
this day my son still says i can't get
the rice right and enough my son try and
make sushi oh yeah
i make sushi
quite a lot to be honest and uh it's
never quite right well if you look at
the rice in a sushi
restaurant it sits in that kind of big
tombola which i think has a high level
of humidity i've got one of those have
you yeah wow hey tom i'm just going to
finish this one useful right because
it's time to annoy me now i mean i love
it yeah but i don't know if people want
to hear me you know
masticating
be very careful while you masticate
never have chocolate on your hands while
you're mastercame what i'm going to do
is i'm going to do this in one mouthful
and it's quite a lot here we go i would
also like to apologize
for the first few minutes of the podcast
basically being myself and billy
chomping away on a treat but it i like
them when they're cold out the fridge
and i thought if we make it room
temperature it gets a bit melty and if i
could use this word a bit claggy
to be honest on it is absolutely
delicious and i'd like you to tell me
that what chocolate that is because it's
very tasty
to be honest you don't know i can't
remember how did you melt it
it came in
buttons
shape
and it actually says on the bag itself
that is specifically for melting the
chocolate
so you know in a bowl immersed in warm
water
and you keep it stirring
and it's dead easy i'll tell you what
that's lovely that then how's your week
been what's been going on well that was
it's better now of course i've had that
cake
tom just threw that across the the
room was that a good shot wasn't it see
if you can hit your head myself right in
the way here okay you ready it's hard
because i've got this thing here
oh that was quite cool better than me
i've seen that within three dimensions
people would have been falling off the
sofa
anything notable happened this week
anything interesting
i've started surfing again right yeah
quite seriously
got a new board or are you leaning back
on your old board bought a new board
um expensive aren't they surfboards oh
they're expensive all right and you're
always scared like when you've got a
brand new one that you're going to ding
it which you are yeah but i carry it
around like it's it's made of like
something that breaks really easy give
me a word
should we say sugar glass like it's made
of sugar glass and that's how i'm
carrying that around just now but my son
has got variant is surfing so it's got
me into it brilliant a father and son
activity yeah i like it have the waves
been
not
not like great but fantastic for me nice
and small and crumbly and not too scary
yeah that's what we want ultimately i
mean you and i learned to surf in new
zealand with
elijah and orlando and our friend dave
and our friend nigel
and i think for the most part
we i mean there was a point where we
were really into it and started buying
books about it and talking about how we
can improve and stuff but then
ultimately we all settled back on the
idea of like if we can go out catch
three or four waves have some fun with
our mates
make a noise when they catch a wave
that's all we're looking for right it's
one of the most difficult things i've
ever tried to learn
i still haven't learned it
i still don't feel like i've got past
the beginner stage of it which is
amazing after all this time yeah but
just to be in the water and um some
dolphins came up and they were as close
as i am to you dom wow which i have to
tell you is about six feet yeah
uh and they were just like they were
catching the waves and just that is
beautiful yeah that's beautiful and also
sea water ocean water
is full of
negative ions which sounds like it's not
good for you but actually negative ions
have been proven to enhance your mood
and make you feel better about it stuff
just everything just general stuff
that's why it's crashing water
apparently and that's why people like to
be near uh waterfalls
interesting
anything happened with you this week i
had a nightmare yesterday a real
a tough time with a piece of technology
well
i think you're
certainly more patient than me but also
a little bit
better with technology than i am just in
terms of solving things
i
had to print out some pages okay
so anyone out there if you've got a
canon mx
860 printer one of the grapes they
should have called it the all bells and
whistles printer because this thing
prints
photocopies scans faxes like you need a
fax anymore somebody just asked me if
facts are my page yesterday carry on wow
but you don't hear that too often don't
you do you remember actually when we
first got to new zealand
ollie was constantly faxing his
girlfriend from the hotel do you
remember he would fax like 15 pages of
stuff yeah i remember i don't remember
that back when faxing was like the cool
thing to do so
this thing
amazing princess massive you know it's
it's a good foot and a half tall by
probably
three feet wide is it new did you just
have had it for a while
but it has a slot
that you put the paper in to fax a slot
that you put the paper in to scan a slot
for photocopying a slot for printing and
then obviously exit places of all those
places exit slots exit slots
so i started out i i needed to print out
six pages and i thought well i can
easily go down to the local print shop
or i can eventually make this printer
word that's just been sat in my office
so i put the pages in the slot have my
computer talk to the printer you can see
that it's talking to it so well you can
see that it's talking to it saying yeah
we're uh we can do this
um
and the printer wakes up receiving the
message and then
it says there's no printer in there's no
paper in the printer so i'm now moving
the paper from four or five different
slots into another one went online
because obviously you can find all this
stuff online and saw
that the actual
place that you're supposed to put the
print paper is almost underneath the
printer hidden away
so i did that i thought right we're off
to the races press print
it does it starts making those very
positive noises
i thought this is brilliant we started
all it does is just print well not even
print just spit out a blank piece of
paper and says the job's done but the
job's not done it's six pages of stuff
and
and this is one of the things that
annoys me the most in my life with
technology or even just anything is
you now you now you're completely
inept because
you've got
a
computer that seems to be doing all the
right things that you've told it to and
a printer that is doing all the right
he's giving you all the right messages
and there's no way that you can step in
between and say wait guys you need to do
this instead so i just
went down to the local print shop and
got it printed out myself but
i lost my temper a little bit
it's annoying that tom it's so
frustrating when you're just like well
now you're just a really expensive piece
of plastic
and i'm doing everything that i'm
supposed to do
and i can't i can't figure out what i'm
supposed to do next is there ink in it
there's ink in it yeah we did all that
everything and i looked online how you
know problem solving and
troubleshooting so if anyone out there
has been in the same situation
as me nightmares with technology yep get
in touch
you know how to but we've been signed i
mean it's it's a nightmare but i mean
it's not terminator nightmare is it no
no we can't tell you what to dress up as
for halloween but we can tell you that
you can save 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes at policy genius
policy genius makes it easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place you could save fifty
percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could save thirteen hundred dollars or
more per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirements
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com
onion in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price
head to policygenius.com onion to get
started right now policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice to get it
right
when it comes to below the waist
grooming there's no need to carve your
pumpkins this halloween because
manscaped is here to upgrade your
grooming experience go from a bite-sized
candy bar to a king-sized candy bar and
join the 2 million men worldwide by
going to manscape.com
for 20 off plus free shipping with the
code onion
hey and i'll tell you what tom it's not
just trimming it's also getting into
fall smelling nice well manscaped
they've got you covered because they'll
keep you smelling fresh all day with
their new refined body wash now it's
smells lovely ladies love it and from
what i hear that will keep away vampires
the lawnmower 4.0 is easily their
greatest trimmer on the planet and did i
mention that the trimmer is waterproof
yes this trimmer is shower essential and
then you can seal the deal with
manscapes liquid formulations their crop
preserver which of course is the
deodorant and the crop reviver which is
the toner
now
they'll make sure that your pumpkins
stay fresh so trust me when i say this
fella
your balls will thank you
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code onion at manscape.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code onion
at manscaped.com
so you know that all people who really
know about um
technology though
people who really know you know like
bill gates and
people like that
they are all worried about artificial
intelligence
do you know why
um no i could guess but go and tell me
i'd like to hear your guess oh okay i
think
they're worried that they will invent an
artificial intelligence that will
very quickly start to think for itself
and overtake humans
i think you've almost got it there
you've almost got it right so once a
machine
can think for itself right
exponentially it will become
more and more intelligent like
nanoseconds yeah as it goes i can now
think
i'll improve and prove improve like
way quicker than we ever could to a
point where
why am i even bothering about humans why
are they here
they're actually not good for the earth
let's wipe them out
and that will happen
like within a second
of a machine becoming an artificial
intelligence so is there not anything
out there now that we asked to think for
itself no there's no real artificial
intelligence there is um
there's a uh
a frog no no is it a type of steam no
it's not a steam it's like pasta test
right and it's what's it called though
what test is it to test for artificial
intelligence do you know that no is it
the name of a famous scientist is it is
it the is it the uh
tesla test
uh nikolai test so close
but i can't remember it ah
but it's the name of it john's gonna
look it up
okay up uh
he knows it
turin test right right well done john
nice work john tremendous knowledge it's
made me cross my legs there and
and once you do that test and they find
there's an artificial intelligence it
could be the end for us all i know elon
musk
talked about the insecurities with
uh artificial intelligence on the joe
rogan show a couple of times
where he had said to joe rogan
we
over at my company
can
create an ai now we have the technology
but we're reluctant to do so
because of
where we can get to and joe rogan was
saying but isn't that the evolution of
life in some way on planet earth that it
moves from
human to
to an a.i and elon musk said well yeah
quite possibly but it probably might be
the end of
humans you know like intelligence as we
know it will just
they just balloon to points that we
couldn't even
because even in our lifetime
the accessibility to knowledge has
ballooned we we growing up doing
homework let's say on
uh
wales we'd have to go to a library and
only based on the books that they had in
the library was where we were getting
our information from nowadays obviously
you put whales into the internet and you
have access to almost every book that's
ever been written about wales so
young people nowadays this whole idea of
like there are no wrong answers we're
now living in a society where people
will not accept that you can sit around
the table and be like well i'm not sure
is it this or is it that people say well
let me just go find it oh siri help us
out what's your thing you know so
it is it is dramatically accelerating
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about all that stuff really
it's interesting
very interesting
so
like a current test like i said if you
guys have had nightmares with technology
like i had yesterday with my
printer get in touch or if you know how
to fix an mx860 printer get in touch or
um
explain how you could maybe
fix it yourself that's i think you would
be able to fix it yourself simply
because
you stay in the pocket of patience in a
way that i don't like i spent
15 minutes maybe trying to fix it and
then i was like i'll i'm done with this
i'm going to go down to the shop i think
you would sit there for an hour and go
right okay that's a machine it's
supposed to do this job it's not doing
it currently i'm going to make it work i
think you're right tom i would make that
my day yesterday yeah i would enjoy that
and get a massive amount of satisfaction
out of having it happen yeah my thing is
the frustration involved in the journey
of potentially eventually it being
successful
far
outweighs getting it to print those six
pages i could go down to the local print
shop print out those pages and i think
you think the longer term thing of well
if i fix it once now that means in three
more days when i do need papers printed
like a rapper drain pie but you live in
the moment and you're not thinking three
days you're just thinking i want six
pages now i'll go down to the store
they'll do that yeah
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails guys
i really think like
there's some there's some real
percolating life with this show now
because it's been a few episodes since
we started making it and now we're
getting more and more comments
you know where you wherever you get your
podcast on our social media and on
youtube there's been a couple of
questions here on youtube that we're
going to get to well we do the
voicemails first do you think oh yeah
should we do the voicemails
all right well let's let's do that
hey billy hey dominic
my name is laura i'm 14 years old and i
have a question for you guys
so where there any bloopers on a lot of
the wings that were so funny that you
still remember them
that was my question i would be very
happy if you answer the question bye
what a wonderful voice lovely wasn't it
where would you say she was from i think
she's probably from
germany or austria or switzerland some
germanically influenced places lovely
accent lower get in touch with us if you
if you want to tell us where you're from
yeah bloopers we did do a few didn't we
there was there is a blooper reel that i
think you'll be able to find on youtube
yeah um that we played at the
the rap party when um the the film had
finished what does rap mean at the end
of a day i know this here we go this is
a sight a bit of a sidebar here uh
rap refers to when we used to be working
with film much more and at the end of
the day
or the end of that particular uh scene
when they knew it was done for the day
they would have to
rewind the film back to the beginning to
put it back into the canister
and rap is an acronym there is an
acronym for wind roll and print
very good though yeah but we don't tend
to wind roll and print too much anymore
because i think it's wind reel oh is
that right but it's all digital now so
there's none of that but we still see
rap yeah we rap at the end of the day we
have a wrap party and at the rap party
we played a blooper reel that everybody
loved and somehow it found its way on to
youtube so i would say get on youtube
and look for
lord of the rings blooper reel and
there's some funny stuff in there peter
jackson is a big fan of
practical jokes and messing about and he
can become quite
giggly and silly at the best of times so
i think when we had time on set and if
someone suggested something
funny he was always into it my favorite
is all my favorite uh bloopers are
always the simple ones and my all-time
favorite one in the lord of the rings
one is where
ian mckellen gandalf says orcs
and so far from auckland
which is a city in new zealand i thought
that was really sweet yeah some funny
stuff there thanks laura
let's do another
hey you too
my name is monica i'm coming to you from
wisconsin i'm so excited to listen to
your podcast
lord of the rings means absolutely
everything to me
it helped me get through my rough
pre-teen years where i was bullied for
being different
and it's because of these movies that i
was so inspired to go out and find my
own adventure and find people who would
love and support me no matter what
since then i've been to amazing places
across the world and found amazing
people to adventure with me i met my
best friend in edinburgh and got him
hooked on lord of the rings also
we're part of this world and we're doing
our very best to make it a better place
for everyone else
thanks for all you do looking so forward
to listening to you guys thanks
lovely thanks monica that's very sweet
it's always sad when you hear somebody
had a hard time at school sometimes
schools like that right
as people try to figure out who they are
it's it's easy to um
bully the person who who doesn't fit
into the
usual stereotypes i think it's school
can be a really cruel
place and when i look back on my school
days i have to admit there were times
where people that i
knew
in my year were probably being targeted
in a way that i wasn't
and i remember thinking well at least
it's not me
because i was the small kid at school
and i was it would be very easy for me
to have been
picked on and i think school can be such
a competitive awful
place and it's a shame my dad was a
teacher my brother continues to be a
teacher
uh lots of my uncles and aunties and
cousins are teachers and they do say
that
in the blink of an eye kids can go from
best mates forever to within 15 minutes
that person's pushed out and they're
being bullied and
in a lot of ways it kind of
it can set you up
for
some of the
some of the hard truths of
being a grown-up you know you're not
always going to be liked by everyone
you're not always going to be
included in group situations and
not that i'm advocating bullying by any
means but i think
sometimes knowing that you know life
isn't always going to be exactly how you
hoped it would be and learning those
tough lessons when you're at school
i don't know there's an element of
rights of passage to that but no one
wants to be yeah i know what you mean
and uh
it is really difficult and i think i
would hope the world's getting better i
think uh kind of accepting everyone i
hope
but
uh
another difficulty is online that people
can bully online and you don't know who
they are and so i think you're right
sometimes when you bully when someone's
being bullied face to face
it's obviously a lesson you know a
horrible one for a person being bullied
but also the person who's bullying
because hopefully if they see someone
being that heart it'll stop them doing
that in the future you would hope but
online there's none of that you can
bully someone and then forget about it
yeah so it's
something i think the online thing that
we
have to look at carefully yeah
it's also important at times i think to
have the perspective of you know if if
you are old enough
and are interested in being involved in
a kind of pub based society that tends
to be
that one guy or girl in the pub who
drinks a little bit too much and at the
end of the night is slinging around
insults and being a bit mean and nasty
and in that particular situation you
just go yeah all right dave nice one as
you walk past something ah you're an
idiot you go okay dave see you next week
and you walk off and you don't think
anything of it it just kind of
you know bounces off you because you
think well they're not super happy and
they've had a bit too much to drink and
they don't really mean it i think
sometimes with this cyber bullying
you suddenly see this piece of text in
front of you and it's permanent and it's
written he said i need to respond to
that i'm being attacked here if that was
someone if you're walking down the
precinct and you walk past someone who
doesn't know you he goes you look like
an idiot in that jacket all right mate
see you later it's not a big deal you
know so i think
some something about the power of cyber
bullying is
a real shame and um
you know they they are trying to kick
a lot of it out now with you know some
of these drives that they're doing for
racism and or anti-racism and you know
making sure that people are
not being targeted but it is i think
probably the worst thing about social
media yeah yeah
great question monica i hope you're
doing it i'm glad it all went well and
i'm glad a lot of the rings helped
during those times same
growing up i love cereal i mean who
doesn't a nice bowl of cold cereal mmm
delicious but then i found out it's full
of sugar it's not very good for you so
what are we going to do about that well
i've been trying to cut down carbs sugar
unhealthy food and i realized i
basically can i can't eat anything until
i heard of
magic spoon cereal
i love magic spoon cereal as well billy
there's nothing better than other
weekend in the morning making myself a
lovely bowl of cereal and maybe having
some cold milk whilst catching up on
cartoons and let me tell you this about
all the healthy things about magic
cereal it's zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of protein and only four net grams
of carbs in each serving that's only 140
calories a serving it's also keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and it's low carb and it's yummy
plus you can build your own box all the
available flavors you can put them in
the way you like them and custom bundle
whether it's cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry cinnamon my personal
favorite cookies and cream you make up
your own box
yeah these flavors were first introduced
for a limited time and they sold out
just like that so now they're back
including maple waffle flavor very tasty
you gotta try them they're delicious and
indulgent perfect for my guilty midnight
snack or first thing in the morning
cereal so go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and try it today and be sure
to use the code onion at checkout to
save five dollars on your order not only
that but magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's back with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
this podcast is sponsored by help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional
therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is a professional
counselling done securely online you get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room
as with traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counsellors
if needed better help wants you to start
living a happier life today visit
betterhelp.com
onion that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
let's do one more
hey darwin billy good day today from
dave and winnipeg manitoba canada's
worst selling author on a satire about
finding happiness
super stoked about podcasts looking
forward to hearing it
would love to see an episode where you
talk about fiction
and maybe about a couple fiction books
that you've read and how they impacted
you in terms of your dreams or something
you learn from them because i think
fiction is a great way to learn life and
lessons about life
look forward to hearing from you and
just want to say
loved you guys so much as mary and pip
and the way you portrayed them
we named our dogs mary and pippin and
they're probably the cutest dogs on
earth
anyways take care
stay safe i can't wait to hear your
podcast
sweet
handsome dog two dogs lovely um
yeah reading is very very
uh formative
and important i think
you know we we have been struggling to
read
as smartphones have come more and more
into our lives but hopefully we're
reading a little bit on smartphones
as well
um
in terms of fiction
one of the things that really stands out
to me
because it was relatively recent
and
an amazing experience was i went to peru
for about two and a half weeks
into the jungle no phone
uh no access to the outside world with a
few friends and i took with me the book
dune
or as you've seen the united states of
america
dune
d-u-n-e-d-u-n-e by the uh illustrious uh
science fiction writer frank herbert in
fact hgrb
[Laughter]
like like sherbet but without the s um
he's probably attributed with writing
the seminal piece of science fiction
literature not to be confused with
professor tolkien who's known for have
written the sentences of fantasy a lot
of people for some reason confused
sci-fi and fantasy i mean they're kind
of
similar-ish world
dune which comes out at the end of the
year starring
timothy chalamet
and oscar isaacs who i work with on star
wars who is
one of the coolest friendliest men in
the world what were we gonna say that
was funny about timothy shallamy i was
going to try and spell his name but
there was no way
i think it's actually timothee timothy
is that not a shampoo
it might be i think he has some sort of
maybe
canadian connection i think it's
timothee anyway this this question
actually began its life in canada yeah
sorry about this um hello candidate uh
manitoba
so i went down with dune which i had
tried to crack into a couple of times
and was distracted by life and i thought
well if i just take this book down with
me and i have nothing else to do at
night
or in the day i'll i'll be forced to
read it
and it is just one of the most
incredible apart from rings it's
probably the deepest dive that i've ever
done into a world you read it right or
did you just watch the film no i read it
years ago and
you know i'd like to read that again
actually
both
two of my greatest um
fiction books of the last few years were
recommended by you oh go on what
ready player one brilliant i loved it
roller coaster i just happened to be
passing a bookstore and i thought oh dom
dom told me about this book way before
the movie and all that
and i loved it i loved it and then you
know the other one about the guy who
goes to india and
shantaram i love that yeah so that's a
couple of great great fiction um
recommendations from mr tom monahan that
i would recommend to anyone hello in
fact that's just jugged my memory my mum
and dad asked me to ask you yep if you
could loan me that book
by that scottish author did he win the
book a prize it's called shoggy i think
shaggy night
it's brilliant my parents and especially
my mom said it's a little bit near the
knockout it's quite dark it's a bit blue
but it's lovely
great story and i said oh billy billy
and ali both read that and they loved it
and they said loan it off i'll give you
that would you yeah i will all right
next time i'll bring it next time i see
you brilliant um yes read more books i
in in all of my kind of artistic
uh endeavors whether that's reading
poetry or looking at paintings or
watching movies or watching tv when you
find yourself
falling deep into a book it's one of the
most immersive experiences ever and it
will stay with you for a long time
that's what i like about books yeah
absolutely
great question lovely question canada
guys if there's a book
that for you change the course of your
life or you absolutely love or you would
recommend to billy and i that you think
maybe who knows maybe we'll start a book
club
get in touch with us you can leave a
message
at www dot speak pipe
forward slash
the friendship onion
well done thanks
i've committed that to memory that was
good
um
we're also getting some comments
on our youtube page if you guys want to
listen to our dulcet tones of course do
that but if you'd like to see our silly
faces at the same time watch us on
youtube and you can leave comments about
the show underneath and there are some
choice comments here hang on let me
scroll down with my mouse just leave
good ones yeah he can leave uh
you can leave constructive bad ones but
don't just be nasty and mean for no
reason why would you why would you be so
unkind
uh
this
is a comment from brendan daniel
who said as an aspiring filmmaker i
think peter jackson was able to do
something so unique
do you think he will ever come to direct
anything like this again
and then he said love you thanks that's
nice isn't it it's nice to get some love
like that uh
hey
you know what i don't think i've ever
seen anyone work as hard on anything as
peter jackson did in the lord of the
rings trilogy
[Music]
one it was done on film
as you remember
so
all all of the footage had to be checked
and something called
rushes rushes which we were always
invited to which is uncommon for a lot
of actors pete jackson said to us right
from the start look you don't have to
come to rushes but if you ever want to
come to rushes we're watching it every
night at my local cinema come along it's
obviously going to be rough i went a
couple of times and i was completely
insecure about it and i didn't go again
because sometimes you know they might
have had three four different um sets
all recording so sometimes rushes was
five hours yeah so pete would film all
day as a director
take a quick break for something e or
whatever and then go into the theater
and watch five hours of their rushes
from the day before maybe
15 takes of
you saying one line yeah brilliantly
brilliantly yeah they can't pick there
was like 15 versions people's like we
might just have to have dumb say it 15
times
that good and then they ended up just
picking one yeah they picked one by
random
so um you know it i so would
well wait
can i just finish that carry on because
i remember fran and phil
fran walsh pete's wife and philippa
boyne's uh fran and peace writing
partner saying to me not only did he do
rushes then he would go home and los
angeles would have woken up by that
point so we'd have to be on the phone
with the studio in los angeles and new
york so he's getting three or four hours
sleep maybe four or five hours of his
lucky at night
first there on set leaving last and i
remember him saying to us all the time
which was brilliant there's nowhere else
i'd rather be remembering saying that a
lot we'd say you're right because he
would sometimes look tired wouldn't he
yeah his hair's always all over the
place but he'd sometimes look like well
man pete you look like you need a good
night's sleep and he'd look at us and
say there's nowhere else i'd rather be
yeah brilliant i'm absolute
anytime peter jackson does anything i'll
look forward to it i love that world war
one documentary he he just did i should
not grow up anything
you know he's doing a beatles one which
we'll [ __ ] a hoop about oh wow i can't
wait to see that he's a massive beatles
fan and i think he's really keen to show
that the beatles continue to love each
other throughout their entire yeah it's
going to be joyful oh it's going to be
lovely i can't wait for that and then
you know when it when he does decide to
do another fiction i know it will be
amazing he's one of the great filmmakers
so but just specifically brandon to to
also answer the question that you asked
do you think he'll ever come to direct
anything like this again
could i put forward
the hobbit trilogy oh yeah
yes
lord of the rings it has some of the
same characters gandalf is in it as is a
billboard yeah i remember that amazing
story that you said that when you and
your friends read the hobbit as kids and
then you started to read lord of the
rings you think well i'm not gonna do
this but bilbo's not even in it that's
how you get so attached to people when
you read a book and i read the hobbit
and i wanted to read another adventure
with bilbo and because it was frodo i
didn't read it
it's incredible isn't it
i really want to read those books again
i'm just not sure when i have
when i will have the time to do it but
i can't wait to do it have you read the
song melorelli no have you no shall we
read it together we could do come here
that might be a fun thing to do if
you've read the silmarillion and you can
recommend it get in touch with us
i'm of the understanding that the
silmarillion is kind of
pre-history how the elves became how the
dwarves became sec secondage second age
sauron he was walking around on earth at
that point right yes so if people want
that perhaps me and dom could do a side
thing of the podcast where we take
500 days or however long it will take to
read the silmarillion sounds amazing
doesn't it yeah yeah let's do it if
people want it we will do it we should
be doing audio books by this point
because why don't we do the silmarillion
do you see my point here yeah i know you
made a good point i mean you do have a a
wonderful voice it's in my mouth yeah it
comes out of you through your larynx and
listen how resonant you are well jj
abrams friend of mine name drop sorry
bob de niro told me i should never name
drop yeah um uh jj told me when we were
doing star wars he was like
a couple of times he said can you bring
the octave of your voice yeah a little
bit and i said yeah okay and then one
time he took me aside
because jj is a funny man he went is
that actually the depth of your voice
now and i went i don't know this is just
the way i taught and he said it's like
dropped three or four octaves in the
last few years
it might be because i eat gravel what
are you going to sound like when you're
60. well you've not seen my dad for a
while when my dad talks down here has he
yeah i mean manchester city what
recently won the premier league and when
i called him up he was excited and said
how'd you feel that i'm absolutely over
the moon
i've just opened a bag of peanuts what
does maureen sound like oh she's gone
higher has she yeah it's like
echolocation now only only bats can hear
her
dominic we're doing a new thing on the
podcast we are oh yes this isn't the
naked part no no no we're not doing that
i've told you we've next now what we're
doing this time is we're going to
listen to a listener oh lovely or
introduce a listener anyway what maybe
ask some questions get someone on who
listens to the podcast get to know
someone get to know someone a little bit
maybe they've got questions to ask us
anyway this week we have the lovely
lauren moran
hello lauren hi
hi guys hey lauren whereabouts are you
i'm in new york i'm like a little north
of the city
nice such a cool city north of the city
so in my mind the city is a little
island is that right
that's manhattan yeah yes so how do you
go north you need to cross the water
no no you just go up i just rain oh
right okay
good is that a stratocaster you have
behind you on your right
you know this actually is my brother's
old room he moved out so that's his i'm
not even sure he has a bunch of guitars
so it's a nice one yeah you should let
me play that lauren i'll give you
something to do yeah
and we see a little hint of david bowie
or bowie depending on yeah so um
yeah he's my guy yeah he's fantastic how
do you have a favorite
bowie album
i guess ziggy stardust just because
that's my favorite song by him not to be
cliche but that's not cliche i don't
think it is and that is your art is it
lauren did you paint that yes
yeah i got freddie mercury over there in
the corner too a couple people nice i
love that that's great could you do one
for the friendship onion yeah and we'll
feature it on the show yes
yeah sure we're not going to pay for it
we don't have any money freebies
we want freebies no it's all good
got any questions for us lauren
i do i have a couple do you really
what do you really you have a question
go on then
oh yes
so you guys worked on the trilogy for so
long you know such a big part of your
life
uh when you were done filming did you
kind of go through like an identity
crisis or was it tough to like adjust
back to normal life after you know
finishing everything
i went i went through a financial crisis
did you really
no have you recovered i think
i think i did a little
bit
um
we wrapped
just before would that have been
christmas of 2000
it was it was just before a christmas
and we all knew that we were going to
see each other again because you have to
do press on the movie and
peter told us that we would be coming
back for re-shoots but i went to
austria with my
to meet my parents and my
brother and i remember
continuing on keeping a diary at that
point and when i read back on that diary
there
there's a lot of kind of like okay
what next like now i have to go back to
looking for a job as an actor and now i
have to go back to
hitting the pavement and paying my bills
with the job that's not transpired yet
and
where do i live now do i live in
manchester do i live in london do i go
to the united states i think there was a
lot of
questioning the great thing about lord
of the rings for me at least was
you knew that in your back pocket you
had a trilogy of films that more than
likely were going to play at the cinema
and hopefully we're going to do quite
well so you you did have a little bit of
a cushion but yeah yeah i did feel a
little yeah it was a weird time you know
we were so in a world and then you're
not in it it's it's very strange
an awesome question good question
also we're all in touch with each other
on a daily basis lauren because we're
seeing each other there was no aspect of
me
necessarily needing to get hold of
anyone's phone number because we've seen
each other on set but immediately it
became clear that like right i need
billy's phone number i need elijah's
phone number and his email address
because now it's not a built-in social
thing you have to you have to work it
you know
that's a great question lauren
thank you
um so i have one question for each of
you actually this one's for billy um
you're seeing with the palantir with the
sauerman's palantir when you film that
that was like super intense um
did you do multiple takes for that did
you act it out the same way every time
or you know how was that for you well um
yeah good question because i remember
that being a different um day because
mainly
the the the dop uh andrew lesni was an
absolute genius with the camera and the
way he lit scenes was so beautiful and
looking at it now i feel like
lord of the rings hasn't really aged
it's so beautifully shot as a movie
um and i remember that day pete says i
want this scene to be shot like it's a
documentary so he got andrew who wasn't
normally on camera he'd be checking
lights and stuff
to actually hand
uh hold handheld camera to do it as if
like it's almost voyeuristic oh what
have we caught here it's you know so
it's
handheld and i remember at a time
thinking god this is so exciting because
the days were normally about tweaking
lights and just making sure you had the
right light on your hair and in your
eyes and you know and that day felt like
you know
andrew was right there in my face as i
had this kind of pound here and uh i
remember it being a really exciting day
and it was really fun and also it's
quite a lot of the other members of the
cast in there right ian was there viggo
was there ollie yeah yeah elijah sean
so there's always there was always a
great feeling when the entire cast got
together because
everyone's helping each other out with
mood and performance and stuff brilliant
yeah were you not usually together on
set or that was like a rarity we we were
but very often the four hobbits would be
together and then you'd have scale
doubles that would represent gandalf or
or aragorn or legolas i don't think it
was
it was all the time that we would be
together but when we were all together
there was kind of a feeling of
celebration
yeah we got very good at talking to
tennis balls off off the back of camera
because you know the height differences
were different so we couldn't always
be in a scene with someone yeah but they
you're right because that day everyone
was sleeping so everyone was there and
the the scales didn't matter as much you
know that was a fun day fun day yeah
yeah
okay so don this one's for you um in
return of the king you know mary wants
to go fight
and tells him he can't but you know you
end up riding into battle with aoen um
did you feel like that was when mary
really peaked like character development
wise or
was that a really important and
significant scene for you
yeah
i think there's quite a few
moments in the book
that mary has that were taken and given
to
other characters
frodo takes a couple of kind of
key moments that mary has in the
fellowship because they thought it made
more sense to build
a relationship between frodo and gandalf
which i was always a little kind of like
oh well i don't have a massive amount to
do in this film and it would be nice to
do
something so
i think i was aware that that was
a big
peak the kind of stabbing of the witch
king and kind of offering
offering to be in battle what was
interesting about that time was i was
spending a lot of time at that point
with bernard hill carl urban
miranda otto all three of them being
kind of
warriors very capable
head strong
you know kind of powerful performances
and i felt
very
excuse me very kind of undermined
throughout most most of that time
because mary had nothing to do he just
kind of
stood there and took it or couldn't
really speak or you know as hobbits we
tend to do a lot of our performances on
our knees so you i mean you're literally
a lot smaller than people but i just
quite rightly
i felt like i didn't have a voice and i
was kind of being slightly
marginalized and then you have these
moments and what's brilliant about p
in terms of his direction was
even if you weren't you know
one of the massive key
characters in the trilogy like gandalf
or like frodo he still made your
journey feel important so in that day
when i'm stabbing the witch king and
miranda you know ultimately kills him he
he was sayings was you know this this is
the moment for you this is the big
moment in in your character's storyline
so we need to really
hit it you know so yeah it's exciting
times and
as hobbits i think for the most part
you're always in the shadow of the
taller stature characters so when you
can do something there's a little hero
like
it's a good day on set
um so i guess this is for both of you if
you guys didn't play marion pippin who
would you have wanted to play
[Music]
it's a fun question i mean it's hard to
say now after watching andy be so
wonderful at gollum but gollum's a
really interesting character i think
yeah
yeah i mean the the
double-edged element of golems really
cool um
i think
certainly as a young man watching what
vigo did
as aragorn and some of those amazing
opportunities that he had to kind of
shine as
the man
was
you know you always kind of think what
that would be fun but then you look at
vigo and you think well there's no
chance that you can't be as
he can't be as handsome as viggo with
his face all covered in dirt and horse
[ __ ] he looks incredible you know
um he's just there's some something
magic about vegan i remember my mom
saying the same thing you know my mom
said he's obviously objectively a very
handsome man but my mom said he's much
more handsome when he's a mess when he
stares all over the place and he's
sweating and he's got you know blood and
mud all over him so
hey great question it's true that he
broke oh sorry no no it's all good
did he break is it true i heard he broke
his toe when he kicked the helmet yeah
in that scene when they go looking for
you that's true
yep it's his own fault he shouldn't have
kicked a helmet you know
everyone thinks he's an amazing hero he
just shouldn't have kicked a helmet yeah
yeah yeah there you go what about you
lauren what do you do up there in in new
york
um i used to be a photographer i
actually went to school for filmmaking
documentaries i did um concerts and like
fashion week in the city but i'm
actually going back to school in
september for forensic science so i'm
like
you're totally switching it up
well definitely keep doing your art it
looks amazing in the background there
yeah thank you
well thanks for being part of the show
lauren we really appreciate you taking
some time to chat to us
um good luck with everything in the
future
thank you very much lauren if you have
time to draw a friendship onion please
send it in
thanks guys see you lauren bye bye
bye
billy and dom eat the world
it's time for i think my favorite part
of the show oh what is it john it's
billy and dom eat the world
at some point in the future we'll put in
a song or billy or polly putting a song
a jolly little titty billion dumb like
we like eating and drinking stuff
[Music]
yeah you can finish it
something like that if you want to
suggest lyrics for the billion dollar
meat the world thing let us know but
guys this is exciting i suggested this
this week
this is my all-time favorite coconut
water and i'm a massive coconut water
fan harmless harvest
organic coconut water now i'll just tell
you this right off the bat guys not
cheap
no it's very expensive defensive but it
is this is strange that you picked this
because you no we're doing this not only
have i had it
it's my favorite yeah it's pink in color
it's pink now the reason why it's pink
is because it's made with a specific
type of young
thai
coconut
it seems they say here on the bottle
that the coconut trees that they use are
all sustainable and that they continue
to you know plant coconut trees because
of that so ethically they seem to be
doing the right thing if i've had a bad
day
or let's say maybe the night before i've
eaten you know a lot of food or maybe
i've had a couple of extra drinks that i
wanted to do or i'm
particularly tired
i will treat myself to a harmless
harvest
organic coconut water is there anything
else we know about oh located in san
francisco we went to san francisco do
you remember and we were surprised by
how freezing cold it was it was freezing
now
what there's 133 team members in this
company living and working in thailand
hello team members of thailand thanks
for the coconut water i love that
country if you guys want to sponsor our
show in fact i remember
years ago
my publicist said to me uh let me know
if there's anything in particular
branding wise that you really like and
maybe we can reach out to them and i
said if we can get a sponsorship deal
with harmless harvest i would love that
because they're my all-time favorite
coconut pan down a bit because i think
it tells you a bit about the company and
i like what i read they
said no absolutely none well they may do
it now because i like this company
look
they wanted to move beyond the standards
of organic farming into a model where
farmers realize better personal and
planetary outcomes by transitioning to
regenerative cultural
agricultural practices that wasn't easy
it was not easy you can have a little
drink of coconut oil in a second i think
what they're saying there is
small-ish companies only 152
members is that right
and they are making a product that is
self
sustainable um
last couple of things to say why pink
coconut water can turn pink when the
varying levels of antioxidants interact
with elements such as light sunlight
instead of hiding this natural variation
harmless harvest use it
by adding a little bit of vitamin c or
citric acid
and the coconuts are young thailand nam
hom coconuts from the samut sakhon
region hello anyone listening to us from
the samit sakon region thank you for
this lovely coconut water let's try it
yeah
here we go guys
you see that that's lovely that though i
can't tell you what i like to do with
this it's a bit weird and i'll sometimes
do this with other drinks
to sustain
the amount of juice that you get out of
it
i
drink the coconut water with much more
air than i would another drink so
instead of just coconut water
i had maybe 50 air at the same time
let me try that
why is that so special it's almost as if
it's like
like
super packed with the flavor of coconuts
you can really taste it much more than
other coconut water like as if the meat
of the coconut is is actually in there
what's lovely that i'll have some more i
was recommended this
by an ex-girlfriend we were walking
around
a very well-known supermarket organic
supermarket which i won't which i won't
name because yeah yeah but they don't
sponsor the show
and she said have you ever had harmless
harvest coconut water and i said no but
aren't other coconut waters
kind of the same that coconut water is
four times cheaper than this and she
said trust me it's five times better and
i would say
it's
17.4 times better and you're only paying
four times as much right so it's like
you're actually making money so you're
saving is it 8.49 if i'm doing maths now
here's a thing though yeah
a sad fact oh god
coconuts kill more people every year she
asks yeah
yeah what do you think of that
it's terrible refrigerators and cows
individually kill more people than
sharks but there are these crazy myths
around these animals like cow ever
killed someone
with a refrigerator can we find that out
if anyone knows any information about
cows killing refrigerators get in touch
with us yeah uh friendship onion at cast
media dot com with a k i'll tell you
what john that is
absolutely delicious
we've spent a little bit of time in
thailand you and i oh i love that i love
thailand i hope that at some point in
the future we might get to do it again
maybe with your family we can all go and
hang out some of my my i stammered there
don't worry about that
some of my favorite memories in thailand
were with you yep in bottle beach oh on
the beach
and someone would come over and say
fresh coconut from that tree and you go
what that one right there and you go
yeah i'll go get it they'd climb up
cut it off and for some reason because
of the insulation of the coconut
what was freezing cold oh
lovely
dom that's just taking me back as i sip
this harmless harvest
right back to thailand and drinking a
coconut on the beach
guys
if there's anything that you like or is
it is a food or beverage curiosity from
a part of the world that we me might not
have explored
let us know how we can get hold of it
maybe we'll feature it on the show
obviously you can email us friendship
onion at cast media.com that's cast with
a k let us know
that that is absolutely delicious can i
give it max a 10 for our three things
that we mark out a 10 for yeah so what
what are the what are the categories
flavor flavor
um aesthetics
what does it look like yeah and how
useful is it in your life brilliant
memory thank you
go on then mark's out of 10 all those
three tastes
it's a tendon it is there's there's
nothing wrong with that yeah
looks
i don't like that you i think you used
to be able to see into the bottle a
little i think there was a gap at all
there is a little gap but i'd like more
because i like the pink thing yeah and
it used to it used to be
that they weren't all pink i don't know
if you remember that and you'd look for
a pink pink one so now they've added
something good stuff
that makes it pink but i think harmless
harvest assume that the pink puts people
off but i like pink i like it as well so
what i'm going to do i'm going to take
two marks off of that
i like the packaging so i'm going to
give that an eight an eight out of ten
and then what's the other one the other
one is how useful is it oh useful is
that really yeah yeah
oh yeah that's right well it's useful
i'll tell you what it's just folding
what what is coconut water good for
dehydration so that's good yeah
and i think it has does it have a small
amount of potassium in it or is that i
might
reach you may be thinking of a banana
yeah no it's also very good for your
skin right so i'm going to give it
but would you add it to things well you
could add it to a curry couldn't you
like a thai curry or something like that
you can add it
but it's so
we don't want to keep bringing up the
expense but it's quite expensive
expenses so i would use a cheaper one in
a smoothie right you know what i mean
yeah yeah and i keep this for drinking
which probably brings it down again to a
seven
so
ten plus eight plus seven
is a hundred and forty-five you could
tell me any number and i wouldn't know
because i'm not good at maths
twenty-five 25 out of 30. you've dropped
five points somewhere i'm going to give
it out of 10. it's a out of 10 it's a
10. i agree with you bills
perfect
aesthetic
i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it an eight i like the
white bottle i like the kind of
handwritten type vibe going on there
and then ease of use i agree i don't
think it's that easy to use because i
think it's so
uh tasty and moorish that you want it on
its own so i'm gonna give it a six so
that's a ten plus seven plus six twenty
four twenty four
ding ding ding ding ding
not bad guys
hey no twenty three
ten plus seven
i thought you said eight the first time
i might have because i was adding up in
my head you know me in numbers i'm not
good
i couldn't tell you right now what 13
plus four is well you couldn't that was
difficult
16. what's 20 17. what's 20 of 80
no chance no really 20 of 80. yeah
is
10.
how could you get that is that right no
oh 20. no i don't know wow that's great
it's just not i think i have this thing
called discalculia well we're here look
i'm going to stick on this one 10 of 80
10 of 88. so what do you think 20 is 16
yes
we've cured you yeah of your what did
you call it
this calculator it's basically dyslexia
for numbers i mean like you had to teach
me it was you in fact that taught me how
to do the tipping yeah in the united
states where you just move the decimal
point over to get the 10 and then add
another 10 for your 20. i did not know
that but i will consistently embarrass
myself just with rudimentary maths where
my mom and my dad all will be something
like well
whatever it's uh it's seven plus six and
i'll go
[Music]
i'm just gonna disappear away it's
embarrassing
guys
brilliant billy and dom meet the world
please send us more suggestions we want
them
and uh that was an absolute smash hit
there was an absolute smash hit i'm
going to finish that now done lovely
harmless harvest organic coconut water i
taste the rainbow one of those skills
there's only one color it's pink
hey well that's the end of the episode
is that it that's it that's all wolves
get tamed for i'll be taking my uh
coconut walter home with me me too but
it's hardly any left it was delicious
guys if you want to get in touch and
let's let's try and make our show number
one come on not only number one in the
film and tv chats let's make us number
one in the world that's that's what we
want it's a universe if you want to do
that you have to subscribe
rate
give us a five-star review the great
thing about subscribing means you don't
have to go look for us each week it'll
just simply show up in your phone if you
give us a five star rating and a review
it means that we fly up the charts and
then we can call up joe rogan and be
like ah in your face joe rogan we're
number one and then he'll absolutely
batter us with one hand he will batter
us yeah he would break his hey you can
email us at friendship onion at
castmedia.com and also obviously if you
guys want to leave a voice message for
us telling us anything about what's
going on in your life or maybe you have
a question that you want to ask or how
lord the rings has completely changed
the outlook of your life get in touch
with us www dot speak pipe
forward slash the friendship onion
great memory
guys we'll see you next week and
unfortunately we ran out of time but
next week we'll talk about that time
that you and i stole that camel in saudi
arabia headed out into the desert we
never thought we never thought we'd see
that
sea water again i didn't i didn't
see you next week guys goodbye
[Music]